Democrats in Congress House and Senate
are pushing Republicans to hold hearings
on Capitol Hill featuring the women who
have accused Donald Trump of sexual
misconduct the women who are the victims
of Donald Trump's behavior for years and
years and years the Democrats want to
bring these women to Capitol Hill and
allow them to tell their story and that
absolutely should happen that way we can
hear from the women themselves there's
been too often where we only get to hear
the media reports or we hear the the
horrible spin coming from Fox News
calling these women liars and cheaters
and just disgusting names let's hear
from the women themselves let's hear
their accounts of it let's get it on the
record let's have it read into the
Congressional Record so that future
generations can understand how badly
this country screwed up let's play that
Access Hollywood tape on the floor of
the House of Representatives and
preserve it for all of eternity people
need to understand and remember what
Donald Trump has said and done and they
need to understand that a pattern of
disgusting behavior is beginning to
emerge either Donald Trump is a sexual
deviant
or he is the victim of one of the
biggest conspiracy theories or excuse me
conspiracies against him that I have
seen probably ever because it would take
a concerted effort by various women who
of all at some point been near Donald
Trump somebody organizing them
fabricating these stories and then
getting them to come forward against the
president and yet according to Donald
Trump who says all of these allegations
are false that had to have been what
happened right or more realistically
Donald Trump likes to sexually harass
women either way it's worth hearing
their stories and it's worth Republicans
finally stepping up and saying you know
what we're not going to be the party
that covers our
our eyes and our ears and pretends that
these women don't exist we're not going
to be the party that shames the victims
of sexual assault anymore
we're not going to be the party that
assumes every woman in this country is
lying about it Donald Trump's so far is
one of the only people in this country
who has had this many allegations come
out against him and remain unscathed
this is about justice for women in the
United States powerful men think they
can get away with anything and for too
long in this country they have been able
to do it well that all changed just a
few months ago powerful men began to be
taken down because women came forward
and told the world what they had been
doing and long before that women were
already coming forward and telling
everyone what Donald Trump had been
doing behind closed doors and sometimes
in public in full view of everyone it's
time for their stories to be heard by
Congress and it's time for Congress to
take them seriously